today we're going to explore what
happens when edge computing meets three
distinct industries
this is the future of today I'm going to
be talking to Luca Marchi an expert and
leader in the retail industry so look at
thanks for joining me here today what do
you think is going to be the opportunity
to transform the retail industry with
introduction to that computer retailers
they gather a lot of data about the
consumer both internal and external but
the main catchment is the cashier what
you bought at what price and when how
frequently you buy it but think about
how many different products you look at
in a supermarket all those things are
not really captured so you can use this
market of Isis in different areas of a
store and collect those touch points and
understand more deeply your customer
behavior so really the benefit of edge
computing in the future of retail is
really going to come for the power of
personalization yeah I totally agree
personalization is going to be so
important you need to sell to everybody
but with very different and specific
customer experience so what do you find
most exciting about this emerging world
of edge computing in the retail industry
well I believe there are three things
that are super exciting the first one it
could be the fully automated store the
second one is the ability to leverage
data that is not generated in the store
and the third one is a complete
immersive experience characterized by
virtual reality or augmented reality
which kind of brings us back to then the
other part of the equation in for the
retailers on the pressure that are under
economically is how to do so how to
introduce these capabilities at lower
cost so edge also has the great
advantage of the cloud of being flexible
and scalable this really helps the
cost-effectiveness of integrating and
deploying an edge network also the
maintenance costs are very limited
because you can still manage them
centrally but you are able to deploy
different software according to the
different situation so look at I really
want
you for being here today up it's going
to be exciting and I'm glad to have you
here on board with us to take us through
that journey
now welcome here thank you for bringing
your expertise in the area of financial
services
what does edge computing mean to the
financial services industry with edge
computing we're able to go that next
step of engagement with consumers
anywhere anytime right so we have ATMs
and an ATM environment currently today
there are cameras we want to make sure
it's a safe environment but also in this
situation where there is fraud they have
the data collected to be able to you
know look at the log files and see what
happens that's all post event though so
what we can do now is in real time
identify that we have a risk either to
human safety or to fraudulent behavior
and with that alert within financial
markets for example in trading no
decisions have to be made so rapidly in
that environment and you know the
latency network bandwidth and sending
things for the cloud to make excision
this just is prohibitive to the ability
to bring those analytics right down to
the edge where the data is created at
the network and then alert for decision
making in milliseconds can be a huge
differentiator and games to me it's a
very exciting time in our industry well
Val thank you so much for being here
today thank you for your insight your
expertise
so if I want to thank you so much for
being here today so let's talk a little
bit about the distinction between 5g and
edge because we use them interchangeably
sometimes but in fact they're quite
different aren't they
absolutely so each use case can also be
done in 4G edges independent of 5g but
5g will provide a whole new set of
opportunities or use cases that never
existed in a 4G environment a classic
example would be a use case which
existed in 4G but it may not have those
latency may not have those networks
slicing features may not have those
bandwidth and so its ability to be
powerful or impactful would be limited
5g will transform it 5g is the fuel for
education absolutely that's a right way
of putting it the farmer CIO for a telco
what should I be thinking about in terms
of my future where I need to be taken
the business we talk about their
industry in three strategic imperatives
the first one is digital customer
engagement how do you improve the
experience for the end user the second
one is network and cloud agility how do
you leverage cloud virtualized networks
etc and then the third one is Enterprise
transformation it's really kind of comes
down to accelerating delivery of value
reducing operating costs and increasing
efficiency and getting a deeper return
on investment absolutely I mean the
telcos are going to be the key enablers
for ensuring that the industries take
advantage of the 5g this was a great
conversation I appreciate your expertise
and all the things we've had to say
about the toko industry the world of the
5gs computing thank you thank you very
much Rob it's exciting really enjoyed
this conversation
[Music]
you